in der schule geht es nie um
masturbation ist die zweite stufe ist
küssen dritte sex entführte anal kinder
aufzuklären war noch nie eine leichte
geburt wird so abdecken
darum führt die britische regierung 2020
sexualerziehung erstmals verpflichtend
als unterrichtsfach 1 haben wir kondome
und gibt richtlinien vor damit an jeder
schule die gleichen inhalte gelehrt
werden lassen
das wirft eine frage auf das wurde den
kids denn bisher beigebracht ich hatte
schon vor der pubertät 6 darum haben die
schüler und ihre eltern eingeladen um
sich frühere und aktuelle aufklärungs
videos aus aller welt anzusehen
genug über töten deshalb der beste film
sehr bildlich gefolgt von der offensten
diskussion über sex die sie je geführt
haben ich mache es am liebsten von
hinten ich höre mir das nicht mehr an
auch gut